[Music]
ladies and gentlemen this is day one of
retirement and i
am miserable i don't think i can
remember a time where i was more bored
out of my mind i don't know what you're
supposed to do in retirement but i'm
pretty sure this is not it
see i looked it up on google that was my
first mistake quite frankly i think
they're about to get shut down by the
ftc
for monopoly laws so that's what i get
says retire on a cruise ship with less
than a million dollars and obviously i'm
broke
i said oh cruise ships sound kind of
nice this time of year nothing
really happened to affect them right i
mean some people say the cruise ships
are very nice to be on
and those some people are complete
idiots guys i'm here to share with you
some of my footage
and it's miserable as you can see almost
no one's here you know what it is
cruise ships are a glorified hotel
that's what it is that's all it is they
have
bad food but it's free they have a pool
that the same tin drunk people are
always in
and they have a room that smells like
that weird combination of human waste
and clorox
and that's about it guys that's really
about it that's all really cruises have
to offer for you
actually i did think of a difference you
can leave a best western
you're not going to leave your carnival
and then the cruise ship just has rooms
like this which
i don't know what the hell this is
supposed to be is this the weird room
where epstein sacrificed the young boys
this is strange
but probably the worst part of all of
this is you can't get a decent cup of
coffee guys
this coffee's so weak so old i had to
ask you know what
type of coffee is it who who makes this
kind of coffee
they show me this guys it's joe biden's
coffee
i mean no wonder it's weak right and you
know another problem is it's been like
24 hours since i've called someone out
on social media
and i'm you know getting a little bit of
the shakes i thought this would be
easier to kick
guys i honestly think cruises are just a
total waste of time and i think the rest
of the world is like realizing that too
i mean look how much like the carnival
cruise line just crashed recently
because it's terrible who would want to
do this i hate it i'm ready to go back
to work guys
i can't i can't do this anymore in fact
i
i don't even think i'm gonna last
through today guys i think
i think i'm gonna go back to the office
right now
guys thanks for watching that video if
you want to be happy unlike me you can
go watch will skoda's new series on
happiness he just uploaded it the secret
to happier he's a good friend of mine
and he put an insane amount of work into
this here go check them out link in the
description bye